beyonce's team this week had to  retroactively change one of the songs on  the album after intense backlash for the  use of an ableist slur when i hear  lyrics like  yummy yummy yum make that bummy heated  make a pretty girl talk that whiskey  till i'm tipsy glitter on my kitty cool  it down down down  my pretty bad bad make the bad bad  glitchy fine fine fine fine for fine  fine  liberated living like we ain't got time  yada yada ya yada yada ya yada yada ya  bom bom kaka spazzing on that ass spazz  on that ass fan me quick girl i need my  glass when i hear those lyrics  i am not especially offended by the word  spazz probably the most reasonable  response to a song like that would be to  recoil and disgust  and to be offended by the vulgar  stupidity and shamelessness of these pop  industry parasites who wish to make our  children dumber while feeding on their  souls and their minds like some kind of  brain-eating amoeba